ben affleck drops the wedding ring and  et has the exclusive pics the 42 year  old actor was spotted driving around Los  Angeles on his motorcycle over the  fourth of July weekend without his  wedding ring he also ran errands in a  black SUV including a Starbucks top  where he once again was without his  wedding band the Batman vs Superman star  just returned to LA from a family  vacation in the Bahamas with Jennifer  Garner and their three kids the trip  came right after the couple announced  their divorcing after 10 years of  marriage oddly enough when Ben was  snapped leaving that vacation in the  Bahamas he was still wearing his ring  you